i'm on a station about 20 30 40 i don't
actually know i don't know where i'm at
but like 30 minutes before the polish
border maxim schmierkovsky has arrived
in poland the 42 year old dancing with
the stars alum who has been documenting
his time in ukraine amid the current
russian invasion revealed on his insta
story monday that he made it onto a
train headed for warsaw writing that the
situation at the train station is insane
max notes that even though he's a big
man with nothing but a backpack the
whole experience was traumatizing adding
that he was in a train cabin with four
adults and seven kids that normally
holds just three people quote there's
usually up to 30 people in this
particular wagon we were told we have to
fit 135
walkways are packed people everywhere
it's sweaty and claustrophobic the
ballroom dance pro adds that watching a
young boy hysterically cry as he said
goodbye to his father
finally broke him meanwhile maxim's wife
peta murgatroyd reposted his update to
her own instagram account with a strong
message of encouragement maxim you can
do it get back home i am so [ __ ]
proud of you for helping those kids on
board later he shared an update that he
was close to his destination i let us
out
we had some
fresh air and
went to the bathroom and now we're going
back
and this is the train
so uh there's one two now that i see it
from the outside yesterday was
night i had no idea where we are but
one two three four five cards
about 130
some people each there's one wagon
that's all
um one card that's all
sicker
kids and people so it's not as packed
but all the others are packed to the
break and it's crazy keep you posted and
finally on tuesday he shared this post
confirming he made it to poland posting
both the ukrainian and polish flags of
course all this comes after maxim
revealed on monday that he had been
arrested in kiev and was planning to
head to the border i got arrested like
food outside of here
but i began all good promise but for me
it was just a reality check you know i'm
gonna try to
make my way out
i'm gonna try to
start getting towards the border max has
been speaking out on social media for
the past week after russia first invaded
his home country honestly i'm getting
really emotional you know me i stay
strong
and i don't show it but
but
i want to go back home